a general principle of mental health is
that the less we are able to express the
more unwell we get
it's when we have to stifle our rage
sadness or fear that we start to develop
secondary symptoms sleeplessness
paranoia bitterness poor digestion just
as our Spirits can lighten and our
Horizons expand once we can find a way
to lend outward form to our pains
however the problem is often one of
occasions we may in theory be ready to
say and feel all sorts of things but our
outward circumstances may be highly
unconducive to free expression
perhaps the person we'd really like to
say something to is dead or they may
just as problematically be distracted
fragile or frightening
we then make the error of imagining that
there can be no point in speaking and on
this basis stifle our emotions to our
increasing cost but this is to miss out
on an unexpected Quirk of our psyches
what may matter most in many situations
is not as we might think that the person
we need to speak to is actually able to
hear what we have to say
but rather that we have a proper
in-depth chance to say it anyway
there can be as much benefit in shouting
our feelings to a deserted Beach a large
pillow or an empty chair as there would
in having a lengthy dialogue with an
intimidating parent or an obtuse lover
this technique in this tradition may be
to write a letter that we never send
either because the person in question is
no longer alive or because we just have
no expectation that what we could write
would remotely be understood
the discipline of writing a long letter
has the effect of galvanizing our
hitherto confused and disparate emotions
and forces our intelligence to lay out
our story in a systematic and
emotionally logical way
as we write we turn what might have been
an incoate SOB into something
intelligible plausible compassion
inducing and moving we go from I hate
you so much or why why why to a full
leisurely recap of how we felt why we
suffered and what the legacy of our
injury has been we can be like a
grown-up lawyer making a case in a
courtroom of adults on behalf of a
frightened or muddled child
we can take our absent reader into the
details of a story that they refuse to
see existed and may have done their best
to silence we're giving ourselves an
opportunity to feel legitimate in our
own eyes
we may realize that the real audience we
needed all along was ourselves
we suffer unnecessarily when we think
that the only form of catharsis is one
that can unfold in the physical presence
of a person who damaged us our freedom
is fortunately far greater than this
because the real skeptic we need to win
over and explain our full story to is
chiefly and crucially always ourselves